so hello my name is Chelsea parlot pel
and today I want to talk to you about
building machine learning web apps using
shiny for
python now it sounds like you heard a
little bit about this before of course
from all the other wonderful shiny talks
we have but just to review shiny for
python is a tool that allows you to
build Interactive reactive and scalable
web apps that just work with the already
rich machine learning ecosystem that
exists in
Python so throughout this talk I'm going
to share some examples of how I've used
shiny for python in my machine learning
workflow and I just want you to ask
yourself where could shiny for python
fit into your machine learning
workflow now I'm not coming to you today
as a developer who could give an incred
incredibly complex and detailed talk
about the inner workings of shiny for
Python and exactly how it's implemented
rather I'm coming to you as a shiny for
python user and I want to tell you what
that experience is like so that you can
see if it's something that you want to
implement in your own
workflow so why am I giving you this
talk if I'm not a shiny for python
developer well let me set the scene so
it's last year before our studio com
and none of you knew that shiny for
python was going to be announced but I
did because I spent the summer working
with the developer team to build apps
and create educational materials to help
people learn how to use shiny for python
in fact if you go to the shiny for
python front page you might see one of
my apps on that front page like this
one but more than that I'm a professor
and while a lot of you probably don't
spend your day-to-day time in front of
dozens of
undergrads I think it's data people a
huge part of what we do is teach because
what is teaching but explaining
complicated complex and difficult topics
in a way that is easily
digestible and I found through my
teaching that shiny for python apps
really helped me accomplish that goal of
communicating difficult things in an
easily digestible way for instance
here's an example of an app that I use
in my deep learning class this is
demonstrating a certain method that goes
with computer vision models that
basically tells you what about an image
was important to the computer vision
model in classifying that image so here
we see a picture of some elephants and
you can see that the model thinks that
these are elephant and on the right you
got a heat map showing you exactly what
pixels were important in making that
classification of elephant and here you
can see it's things that make sense
right like ears and Trunks and using
shiny for python apps allows me to get
my students involved and to interact
with the material that we're
learning now shiny as a framework is not
new as a lot of you know shiny came out
in
2012 for R and in the next about 10
years it has become a beloved tool for
making web apps in the our community now
last year shiny for python was announced
and I think that that just means that
the community of people that is about to
fall in love with shiny just
expanded now I mentioned before that I'm
a professor but if you forced me to put
a label on myself I would call myself a
statistician so as you can imagine I
fell in love with r and all its
Associated tools very early in my career
but I currently teach in an engineering
department which means I am forced to
teach all of my classes in Python the
PRX are in Python the classes after mine
are in Python and just to be honest a
lot of my students are more comfortable
in Python and I think that might be
relatable to a lot of you maybe your web
developers your boss your whole team
your engineers someone else uses Python
and so now you have do and the beauty of
shiny for python is that we can use the
shiny framework which a lot of us may
have fallen in love with when we were
using it in R and we can leverage it
with all of the power that python
has and I joke a little bit about being
forced to teach in Python but I have to
admit python has a great industry
standard very rich ecosystem of machine
learning packages like pyit learn
tensorflow Caris and and pandas and now
we can Leverage The Power of these very
established machine learning packages
with the shiny framework using shiny for
python so I want to tell you about three
different times you might want to use
shiny for python in your machine
learning workflow and the first time is
when you need
interactivity now as a professor I know
that interactivity is key to deep
understanding look sometimes your boss
or the CEO just wants a oneline memo
telling them what to do or they want a
Word document with the information that
you have found but in cases where deep
understanding is the goal interactivity
is going to be key for that and shiny
for python can provide that
interactivity for you for instance
here's an example of an app that I use
with my students to teach them about the
differences between different
classification models as you can see on
the screen there's a bunch of different
things that my students can change they
can change the data set they're looking
at and they can change different
hyperparameters for our various models
those are then going to interact with
the graphs that are shown on the web
page and it allows them to explore and
ask questions about these different
classification models and therefore
engage and get a deeper understanding of
how these models make classifications
differently another app that I use is
this app that helps you look at an
assess model calibration and the
fairness of different models especially
with this topic it's really important if
you want people to have a deep
understanding to let them ask and then
answer their own questions as they
engage and as they get curious and
that's what interactivity through a
shiny for python app allows you to do
and we've seen apps like this before
this is another one that I use to
explain item response Theory models and
you can see it has your typical input
sliders that affect a graph but another
thing that I really love is we don't
just have to change graphs in response
to user input for instance in this app
the actual text explanation of the model
dynamically updates as the users change
their different parameters this again
allows them to get curious ask questions
about what happens when you change this
parameter or that one and then get the
answers to their
questions so where might you have
interactivity in your workflow well in
my humble opinion it is in the three d's
the first one is description so when you
have a new data set or you're trying to
answer a new question you might want to
build a tool that allows your co-workers
or your shareholders to explore the data
and like I mentioned before ask and
answer their own questions as they get
curious about it you can use shiny for
python to build a very nice wellworking
no code exploratory data analysis app
that allows people to filter plot and
summarize their data as they explore it
the second D is in development as you're
building models or comparing models you
can use shiny for python at all stages
of that process for instance you could
even build a shiny app that helps people
on your team build an actual machine
learning model or you can use it as a
way to compare different models as
you're trying to decide what is going to
get put in production or even do
something like a Multiverse analysis in
which you look at the effect of
different modeling choices and how it
might impact the inferences or the
predictions that you're
making and the last D is deployment now
the other two bullet points talked about
times when you're in that model
development or exploration process but
you can also use shiny for python once
your model is completely settled on and
you're just deploying it to users for
instance a shiny for python web app
makes an excellent front end for
something like a recommendation system
and because it's interactive it allows
your users to have a richer experience
with your model because they're not just
getting one static prediction
so another time that you might consider
using shiny for python apps is when you
need
reactivity now what is reactivity well
to take a step back one thing I think we
can all agree on is that machine
learning is computationally expensive
whether we're doing training fine-tuning
making inferences a lot of the things
that we're doing take a lot of
computational power and so we don't want
an app that is going to run top to
bottom every time a user changes
something because sometimes in fact I
might even venture to say often times
you are going to be doing things that
are computationally expensive when
building machine learning apps so
reactivity basically refers to the fact
that we are going to minimally render
our apps only things that absolutely
need to change and be rerun are going to
be changed in response to user
input so here's the world's cutest app
this is looking at a computer vision
model and it's basically allowing you to
test out how different parts of the
image are important to the model by
seeing what happens when you completely
cover it up by the way the takeaway from
this screenshot is that if the computer
vision model can't see the fluffy Corgi
butt it is less confident that the image
is a corgi okay back to the app though
this has a bunch of of user inputs for
instance it allows users to upload an
image that they can then use with this
app when someone uploads an image pretty
much everything on the right hand side
of this app has to update right we need
to update the picture we need to update
the occluded picture and we need to make
predictions both for the unoccluded and
the occluded image however if you look
at the other inputs we can also decide
what is going to be included in the
image like what range of pixels are
going to be removed and when we change
that we don't need to update the
original image and we don't need to
update the model's original prediction
because nothing about our user input
actually affects that and so we're
saving the computational expense of
updating that by using reactivity by
saying only render things that actually
need to be
rendered now one thing that is really
nice about shiny is not just that you
get re re activity because that's not
unique to shiny one thing that is unique
to shiny is this inferred
reactivity inferred reactivity basically
refers to the idea that shiny is
deciding what needs to be rendered in
your app based on how you wrote it you
don't have to think about that at all in
order to get a deeper idea of what I
mean let's look at this really silly
demo app here we have an app that is
plotting a scatter plot based on a
sample of data it lets users change
various thetics and then at the bottom
left it gives you a summary of the
sample of your
data when we have this app we basically
have a computational graph that tells
you about how all the different parts of
the app are related to each other for
instance we start off our app with some
data and then if we press the action
button we take a sample of that data
from that sample we might rely on the
fact that users are going to choose the
color and what's on the Y AIS of our
scatter plot
and using that we then build our scatter
plot then of course we have that summary
table which doesn't rely on the Y
variable for our plot or the color of
the dots in our plot but does rely on
the sample that we've randomly taken
from our data now we just built a very
simple computational graph and you can
see that this tells us how the different
parts of the app relate to each other
for instance if I update the dot color
of my scatter plot I have no need to
update my summary table and that's
reflected in My Graph only things
Downstream of changes that we make need
to be updated when that input is updated
now this is an incredibly Simple app and
the computational graphs for your apps
as they grow in complexity is going to
become at some point unmanageable if you
had to manage this yourself but the good
news is that shiny manages it for you so
instead of you having to design and
specify the computational graph for your
app shiny is inferring what this
computational graph should be so you get
to benefit from reactivity without
having to think about the computational
graph explicitly and I know as I build
more complicated apps I am definitely
going to mess up my computational graph
at some point so I'm very grateful that
shiny doesn't even make me think about
it and you can see with even this Corgi
app that looks pretty simple when you
look at it the computational graph gets
more and more complex as you add various
functionality so the last scenario when
I think you might want to use shiny for
python in your workflow is when you need
scalability now the nice thing about
shiny for python is that it's good for
all parts of the process it allows you
to have a smooth on-ramp to build really
fast simple but really good-looking apps
but it also is there to support you when
that app becomes Mission critical and
you have to scale it up and get it ready
for
production a lot of other web app
Frameworks focus on one portion of this
process there's a lot of great web app
tools out there that allow you to spin
up apps incredibly quickly and get a
pretty good-looking result While others
Focus specifically on getting your apps
ready for production when you need a
very stable and good-look app that can
be p uh pinged excuse me millions of
times a day by your users but the nice
thing about shiny for python is that it
really can handle a lot of these
different stages for instance it's great
at spinning up really quick apps at the
last conference Joe gave a talk where he
mentioned that the idea for the shiny
framework basically came to him fully
formed in a blink of an eye upon waking
up and he really built a web app
framework that allows you to build apps
in the same way for instance here's an
example that I use in one of my classes
that is basically a front end for
hangman and my students are responsible
for building the back end and just like
Joe this came to me as a fully formed
idea one morning and I said oh I want my
students to build hangman today and in
about an hour I was able to spin up this
very simple shiny app and have something
that looked really good especially given
the fact that I only had about an hour
to spend on
it and I'm a professor I don't have time
to build production level web apps and
using shiny for python allows me to
build things like this where I had an
idea one morning I spent a couple of
hours building an app and my students
literally used it that
afternoon and one of the tools that
shiny for python offers you is actually
something that was mentioned in the last
talk which is this serverless deployment
via shiny live so this is an example of
that app that I showed you before with
all of the classification models and
this is something that I've hosted with
shiny live now through the magic of web
assembly and pyodide you can actually
have these apps run in your client's
browser without actually technically
hosting the app anywhere if you look at
the screenshot all of the information
needed for the app like the code any
data that's relevant to the app is all
encoded and stored in what is admittedly
a very long URL but by sending someone
that URL they're able to run the app in
their browser locally all they need is
that URL and an internet
connection and what does that mean for
you well as the person deploying this
app it means no hosting cost because
you're not actually hosting anything
thing for your users that means they do
not have to worry about what I am sure
is a dumpster fire of a python
environment if you're anything like me
they can just run it in their browser
with an internet
connection if you would like an example
of an app hosted via shiny live you can
use this QR code in order to access a
couple of links to apps that I've built
and then hosted with shiny
life so as you can see Shiny is really
great at building quick easy apps but it
can also support you through the process
of getting those apps production ready
for instance let's say that I build this
Stock app that displays various stocks
with various user inputs and I can build
this in about an hour but then I can
hand this over to a web developer who
can then get it production ready without
having to completely rewrite everything
that already Works they can just add
features as needed to our computational
graph without completely rewriting what
I wrote so again shiny is there to
support you through the beginning when
you're writing very simple apps but it
can also support you when you're ready
to take those apps and put them into
production now one last thing I will say
is that the scalability of shiny is not
just in the apps but also in the skills
when you build shiny for python apps
you're learning about the shiny
framework which is then a skill that is
transferable back and forth to R and
back to python all right I'm almost out
of time so I will end there and all I
want to say is where do you think shiny
for python could fit into your machine
learning
workflow thank
you so we have time for one question
until our next speaker sets
up uh and do you have a question the
question is what is the Fe feature that
you have in shiny for R and you miss
most from shiny for
python I haven't run into anything that
I feel like is missing in shiny for
python yet um I will say the syntax in
shiny for python feels a bit more
intuitive to me you can see if you go on
the website there's a really great log
that compares shiny for python to shiny
for R and there's differences in how for
instance we don't have things like um
like isolate and we have things like
reactive events that are a little bit
different uh in terms of syntax and I
actually find it more intuitive so I
know that didn't answer your question
because I basically said I love shiny
for python uh but that's my answer I
haven't found anything that I feel like
is missing although I know the
developers are working all the time to
expand shiny for
python let's join me in thanking Chelsea
once again the
talk